Radio Disney Music Awards you're excited
for this I'm so excited this is my first
time being nominated for a music award
so I'm very excited and you're
performing today correct yeah are you
nervous excited I wasn't nervous until
like 30 minutes ago in my trailer and I
started getting real cranky and like
like it's like just like clenching my
face like I'm like shaking a little I'm
very nervous I'm excited it's all I good
nerves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're gonna be performing to Britney
Spears I know she's my girl though so
I'm excited
did you have a favorite Britney song oh
my gosh I don't know I'm really ain't a
man on the moon from our newest yeah I
like though I think it's beautiful
now you have a full album on the way
correct so we've got two singles out
what can we expect on the full record um
the full record is gonna have like such
a like big variety of sound so I mean
it's not tied to one sound which I
really like about the album it's a very
personal album I've worked on it for two
years so it's very personal
we're gonna see any collaboration not
that I know of yet but there's still
time would you want to ever go out with
your sister I think there's time for
that I think you know I'm kind of like
doing my thing right now doing like you
know working on just finishing up this
album but definitely some time like I
don't I don't see it as like a not never
gonna happen what's the greatest lesson
you've learned from her cuz she's been
through all of this so it's like you
know not care what people are saying you
know I think she's taught me that she's
very very confident who she is so she's
definitely talking to be like that
I mean she said a lot of us that well
have fun tonight break a leg so nice
[Music]